de nombreux supporters dans les tribunes
des joueurs versaillés sur motivés le
Rugby Club de Versailles voulait réussir
ses grands débuts à domicile dans le
championnat de Fédérale 2 pour cela il
fallait battre ce dimanche 18 septembre
l'autre promu Saint-Malo en première
période Versailles met du riz arrive à
faire des différences et à marquer le
score à la pause et sans appel 19 à 7
pour le RCV en seconde période le doute
s'installe très vite dans le
conversaillé Saint-Malo débute fort avec
un essai marqué dès la reprise et entame
une remontada les joueurs de la cité
royale n'arriveront pas à stopper
l'hémorragie et s'inclineront finalement
sur le fil score final 25 22% Malo
perdez forcément du résultat par rapport
à la première mi-temps qu'on avait fait
on domine clairement la première
mi-temps et puis voilà deuxième
clairement on s'est fait on sait pas on
n'a pas respecté ce qu'on s'était dit
pour la première la semaine dernière on
allait gagner à l'extérieur et c'est
exactement le même scénario qu'on a eu
la semaine dernière où on n'a pas réussi
la première mi-temps mais on a gagné la
deuxième et au final on gagne le match
et eux c'est ce qu'ils ont réussi à
faire voilà un match de rugby c'est demi
on a gagné la première on a perdu la
deuxième et du coup bah on perd le match
on a pris une claque la semaine dernière
on allait gagner chez eux mais du coup
là on va y retourner pour la semaine
prochaine allez à plaisir puis on va y
aller avec plein d'envie quoi pour
essayer de gagner ce match pour gagner
un maximum de points quoi bah forcément
déçu puisque on tenait le match on a
fait une belle première mi-temps avec
avec de belles actions voilà on était
agressif en défense on monte on allait
les chercher et du coup on avait creusé
l'écart et c'est vrai que par la suite
je leur avais demandé à la mi-temps de
continuer justement à être dans ce tempo
là et on a baissé un petit peu
d'intensité voilà et puis je pensais que
mon banc allait apporter un petit peu
plus sur la fin un peu de fraîcheur etc
et au final on a pas été de subir on a
fait beaucoup de fautes beaucoup de
cartons et donc du coup on a joué pas
mal à 14 sur la stratégie sur la fin je
pense que voilà il fallait qu'on prenne
les points et que on aille au moins
chercher le nul quoi on en est on en est
bien on sait que ça allait être
difficile je rappelle l'objectif quand
même qui est le qui est le maintien donc
la saison va être longue on a le
potentiel de l'équipe on a ce qu'il faut
il faut ce qu'on continue à travailler
justement prendre le son de ce qui s'est
passé aujourd'hui pour pas reproduire
les mêmes les mêmes erreurs plaisir je
sais pas si on va les manger mais en
tout cas ouais on va essayer d'aller
faire un résultat chez eux après cette
défaite Versailles se retrouve à 5e
place du classement de la poulie de
federerald 2 prochain match ce dimanche
25 septembre face à plaisir pour un
derby Yves Linois qui s'annonce bouillon
[Musique]